i don't love you you're not special
go home that would have been my that
would have been my message to the
[Music]
protesters
uh they gave the vice president 24 hours
to respond
you have 24 hours it's literally hence
this is uh
there's negotiations there's no way he
uh hello hi
welcome to the podcast uh there's no way
pence does 25th
although he's so [ __ ] at this like
pence is so [ __ ] by
trump's violent criminal followers that
um he might as well i mean that's the
only way to save his reputation
for life because you've lost it with the
you've lost it with everybody
the cuckoos you've lost it with the
cuckoos you lost it with moderates for
even
i mean maybe you haven't lost a monitor
so you've lost it with liberals he can
get he can get democrats back
centrists and democrats yeah if he does
25th but we're not going to take him
that back he believes in
um uh d what's the thing where they run
they put the magic wand they
send magic they send gay people through
an x-ray machine they come out
um bianca hi
we lived through a history
a wild white week it was a wild white
week too
too part dude yes uh
we said that there was going to be a lot
of lucky hearing
it was more than lucky hearing it was
lucky it was
it was it was more than it was way more
than i didn't
i didn't think they would storm the
capital
i i it just it i'm genuinely surprised
now here's
in our defense in my defense neither did
the
capital neither did the police so
i yeah i don't think any i was
actually kind of horrified watching it
of course it was like very sick
it's very what no uh
but i i didn't realize
i didn't realize there was a rally i
realized it because they mentioned like
oh he's having a rally but
jen generally his rally seemed kind of
calm
well he you know what i mean it just
seemed so promoted the rally
because i was gonna do a tweet about it
he promoted a rally like two weeks
before
come on january 6 will be wild
and i was going to write wet t-shirt
concepts and then
in parentheses blood
i know i'm just joking because i didn't
think anyone there to actually be wet
there will be blood
dude and what t-shirts no i didn't i
didn't realize
it was down the street from the capitol
yeah i just didn't realize all the
things were happening
in such a small area yeah um and
as they were they were uh you know like
deliberating contests
in congress i i didn't they the like the
reporters from
they kept leaving what was going on in
the congress for to talk about
they're like there's a lot of protesters
and
i don't i'm not first to believe like oh
my god there's so many protesters
sometimes they say
it's a big protest and it's not a
[ __ ] big problem yes
um and then it just got really weird
it's so
dumb and
anyone on the right who acts like they
didn't
think it would lead to this like what it
where did you think
even when trump tries to plead he's
apparently behind closed doors going
like i didn't think they were going to
storm the capital
giuliani said there was going to be
trial by combat
a half an hour before trial by combat is
yeah
like what do you what does that mean
gladiators like what it was underdone
walk me through that like what what does
that mean
trial by combat um and
so i don't know how he's gonna get out
of it criminally i
now having said that he's him so of
course he'll get out of it
um but this was this is the only thing
that i feel like
even conservatives are annoyed because
that i don't know how many conservatives
they're just not
good enough they killed cop they killed
a cop
they bludgeoned him with a fire hydrant
yeah they
they killed a cop like what do you do
you're annoyed no you should be
disgusted and
demand his ouster and because that
it's so big but here's what i'll say
yeah there's just so much so
these guys have to pick between
one fact
one truth one sort of it's the thing
we've been saying for
months which is if you while the new
york times
is biased a little it's shaded left
right most journalists are left
okay take that into consideration it
doesn't mean it's
fake and that's what it became so it
became
that's fake so that's not even anything
they say is not true
so then they start this other
media sphere where they they straight up
lie they're just lying all the time and
then
trump lies all the time and
they foment i don't know i mean
there were 20 10 to 20 000 people this
protest how many people agree with the
protesters
is a whole other issue but millions
probably over 50 million people
kind of were like well right you know
georgia there are some inconsistent just
[ __ ] like that that's like
no there aren't there are not any
inconsistent they they've counted the
[ __ ] ballots
three times right so what are you
talking about
what are you talking about the guy
called and was like can you find me 12
000
come on they've created this other
media sphere and then all the especially
josh hawley
and ted cruz
they they question the ballots
for their own political game ted cruz
they don't think there's any
they don't actually those guys ted josh
hawley went to uh
taught at oxford like the guy's not
[ __ ] dumb right um he knows what's
fact and what is
fiction like we can that i'll give him
same with ted cruz so these guys
have been playing a game where for their
political gain
they say everything all of these facts
are actually
lies okay they
they foment millions of people
and get them to come to a rally will be
wild
and um
and then it ends up they storm the
capital by the way you know
part of the reason they said storm the
capital is because it sounds like castle
they're that dumb the one's like we
stormed the capital the woman who got
mace cause it sounds like we stormed the
castle
which they've seen in movies uh which is
a cool thing for them
um you know what they weren't looking
for in there
books the books were untouched
group of people it's just a dumb [ __ ]
dumb
so these guys are playing a game where
they're they're lying to
millions of people who are largely
violent people
uh and susceptible to they're just very
suggestible people
they're violent they have guns the guy
brought napalm
five gallons of napalm yeah um didn't
somehow didn't get to use it uh and
these guys are playing like they're
under the impression that if
if ted cruz had been in the capital or
josh hawley
they're under the impression that these
criminals would have seen them and been
excited to see them you're basically
just
you're just you've it's one of those
lighter fluid videos where you're just
[ __ ] putting it on and you think it's
never you think
you think you can control these people
all it takes is
one of them right to go hey [ __ ] the
i didn't like what you said about that
one thing you're dead
and they're playing this game
intentionally
even after they they storm the capital
they're still playing the game and it's
gonna
kill them it will eventually kill them i
truly believe not
maybe not them directly they would have
absolutely killed out uh
pelosi 100 they would have absolutely
killed aoc
they would have absolutely killed adam
schiff
schumer would have been killed um who
else would have absolutely been um
yeah my girlfriend um that she gave me
that beautiful oh
yeah i know she is and um
uh yeah they all the squad would have
been killed
uh iona presley would have been killed
they would have killed kamala
kamala would have been killed they would
have killed it they would have killed
pence mike pence
they were chanting pence's name like
we're gonna
like like the [ __ ] warriors yeah
come out and play so these guys are
the ted cruz josh hawley's of the world
are you're playing
you're lying to get people to support
you yeah
because you can which is not new for
politics let's just
no but not they'll fudge
yeah they used to fudge now they're
straight up lying
because the problem is that the
republican party is so fractured
and they have their identities all over
the place but the one thing uniting
everybody was trump so they were really
for trump not necessarily for uh like
establishment republicans so when
at one point if you just if that's the
guy that's gonna
keep you having a job
i mean they just bet they're just like
okay we're we
have to go with the one guy there's no i
mean there's a video of
all these senators saying [ __ ] up
things about trump
saying how bad he is i mean we all know
that they didn't like him they would
have killed lindsey graham speaking of
which
yeah they would have killed lady g yeah
uh
ladies they would have let go
no but i'm just saying they all know we
all know that they know
this is not like ted cruz isn't this
isn't what he
like truly believes he just wants to be
there
they were [ __ ] but that's where you go
oh this isn't worth it
they're gonna kill you do you i don't
think they would have walked into
they wouldn't have been like josh holly
i [ __ ] with you man
no selfie no way they would have they
would have just
started firing josh hawley by the way is
a combination of me and steve nash and i
don't like it
one bit face math i don't see it i don't
i
it angers me um
so yeah they would they're gonna kill
you
these are not this is a frankenstein
sponsor it's they don't [ __ ]
care yeah no they're not i've never this
is the most
the the the we live in the golden age of
the frankenstein sponsor
um because that's what facebook is it's
all
kind of the same thing that mark
zuckerberg made this thing for friends
and then [ __ ] it's weaponized no
i don't think it is weaponized actually
if you look at
we will allow holocaust denials on here
why
what the [ __ ] are you why and then
finally he was like yeah
yeah oh wait i'm jewish oh
i should i was i just saw my lizard name
i feel like yeah
um i feel like i might be jewish uh
so what's weird go ahead finish it up
i mean it's just they're gonna kill you
and at a certain point
there has to either be
an accepted reality or
anarchy because that's where it goes
it's like
it or what not even anarchy
um because i don't think the military i
mean it the military
didn't i mean the military didn't bite
this time right do you know what i mean
like
at a certain point maybe they do but
that's what these [ __ ]
morons are fighting for is
no recap they're st they're stealing the
election
dog they counted the votes uh none of
the
cases even got heard right because
they're so [ __ ]
flimsy and nonsensical they like one of
the
videos was edited in georgia and that
giuliani directly lied
um and but what they were calling for it
like ted cruz was like justin
just an audit i know it won't change
anything
it's like why yeah they already audited
it
it's counting it's it's counting it's
literally
one of the most basic things that human
beings can agree on
counting that's it's [ __ ] counting
it's not
uh well there's a lot of there are no
[ __ ] a regular there aren't
like the the different there were the 5
000 the guy was on 60 minutes last night
the georgia
yeah the attorney general or not uh
whatever account whatever uh
said there were two dead people voted
and he didn't say by the way i wish he'd
said
by the way they were for trump right two
two dead names
were used to vote um so
it's it's really
incredibly stupid that these guys
are encouraging
and then there's the 150 republicans
that
that were also supporting it and
and now they're just going to go on
being congress people
you [ __ ] encouraged
them storming the capital
and killing a cop a woman on from their
air force woman got killed a few people
die
and and you because of you it's just
[ __ ]
direct yeah it's because of you
it's not my maybe a i don't know
um so i don't see how they can
go on
being elected i mean like they're trying
to get
ted cruz thrown off the bar and all
kinds of stuff giuliani ted cruz
which at the very least should happen i
also just want to understand what's
going on in texas why did you reelect
this guy he doesn't seem that popular
he's not popular amongst his
fellow republican senators i mean they
don't he's like he's
anti-charm no he's one of the least
charismatic people
in public life in the history of public
life he is anti-charm
they all dislike him what did i think he
makes mitch mcconnell
look like cedric the entertainer
uh he's so atrocious i think
what was it i think it was like lady g
said that if he
got murdered on the senate floor like no
one would
no one would try to stop it uh somebody
al franken said
oh yeah about somebody i i like him more
than
ted cruz and i hate ted cruz yeah he
said i like ted cruz the most and i hate
it and i hate that yeah
and the funny thing is on al franken's
website part of his merch he only has
like six
pieces of merch and two of them are i
hate ted cruz mug and hat
so uh he's not a popular guy he's
well but the problem is they get they're
he's famous
so yeah when you're the incumbent and
you have a national profile it's very
hard to get
what's interesting to me is
so after while it was happening and
afterwards obviously like i wanted to
understand
how conservatives and right-leaning
people were processing this because it
goes against
everything they claim they stand for um
and i realized okay they're they have a
point
in that
conservative conservativism and
republicanism and
right-leaning things they are censored
to a certain degree i mean they they
like they're not popular
in like pop culture you know like if you
are a right-leaning
celebrity it's you know you do kind of
have to keep that
a little bit of a secret like i
understand when they
they think they're being censored i
don't think they're being censors but i
understand what they're talking about
it isn't it is popular it's less
veganism yeah and
also you don't win the popular vote and
you know it that's why you want the
electoral college around so you want you
know already it's
not popular yeah um and
the problem is that there is some sort
of like
yeah it's not popular and they tried to
equate that with
other types of oppression and other
types of suffering
but in the end the most far
right the most far left leaning person
can
still say their opinions and beliefs out
loud
and on record they might be more
intolerant like i'm not always agreeing
with
super far left people yeah i mean i'm
from the bay area there's
plenty and i'm very annoying and they're
very confident they're very confident
very they've just opened a vegan
restaurant
that neil just ordered a salad um
but the most far right leaning person
knows that their
views are [ __ ] up and i'm talking
about the fringy fart right so
they do keep i understand when these
people think oh we can't we don't look
it's not fair it's not fair we're also
in some sort of bubble of oppression but
it is
it's so not the same and they want it to
be the same but also what it but
what do they want not popular is
different what they're advocating for
is uh they're advocating for oppression
right where they got what like maybe we
should send the military into dc
for blm right that guy said and then all
the new york times
article writer op-ed writers were like
hey you know
i'm going to die because of this right
no one's going to die because equality
because of liberal
like because of uh
universal healthcare yeah or bathroom
stuff
right no one's gonna die and i think
they get it
so confused and i think human nature
everybody wants to
feel the victim feel victim feel someone
saying like
dude you're kind of getting the [ __ ]
into the stick here yeah and people go
thank you dude you don't understand like
you know and that
what trump did to speak to that part of
their
like craving for victimhood yes it just
it created a monster well that
was that he didn't sorry he didn't
create but he's
he empowered i mean he lied to them
of course he lied he lied
um know that i will never say that name
it sounds like a curse
like i put a curse on someone um uh
he just lied to them of course but isn't
that what people do
some people if you want if i want to
just like snuggle up to you
you just [ __ ] well i mean hitler
genuine
actually said if you want to enslave a
people convince them they're under
attack
yeah and he lie i mean the thing that
trump said that was like
even to the last video i'm like this
[ __ ] is yo
you i love you and you're special [ __ ]
i mean god damn yo like this
[ __ ]
is go has got a touch the funny thing is
and i read some
like in school just when i lived in
germany and stuff
uh you read some of hitler's
speeches and he's really eloquent with
his wording
some of his word you know how jubilation
sounds like a
christian thing yeah we don't use it in
our like he
there's some words that now sound like
hitler but they're
eloquent how do you spell jew okay
so when you read them he is eloquent
with his wording and
but then you see trump who is
ten times the mastermind of [ __ ]
convincing people and he's so stupid
with his wording i mean it's like but
that's
his special touch that's his touch is
that he acts like
he's as dumb as all those stupid people
that right
he wouldn't you know he's golfing at
his own country club most of the time
he's got
he said those people are disgusting he
doesn't want to shake their hands
yeah that's another one of those things
where they think that
he's on their side it's like he's not on
your side
no he's not on he just hates liberals he
was con
he was a democrat until six years ago
yeah until seth and obama
brought the hammer down i mean it was
before that but but uh
anything to do with that i don't want to
okay
thanks neil thanks neil um
the so yeah he is an amazing
he's he's the most
he makes reagan look pedestrian
in terms of his like that speaking to
people yeah
appealing to people's emotions you're
special [ __ ]
we love you you're very special oh
you're oh it's just
i couldn't i was like wow and the fact
that he doubled down and it was stolen
the other side knows it right and the
only person by the way who said stop the
tape was shep smith
really yeah on cnbc he was like stop it
stop the tape we're not playing it
he's [ __ ] lying yeah and everybody
else just like
well this is the president and and uh
it is it was amazing watching it on
i think i watched that on msnbc and i'm
saying people are so
i did watch fox if you watch it on fox
yeah it was
like they had salt in their mouth
they're like
this is yeah not okay yes
this is not yeah right yeah they didn't
know
they they'd never they'd never they
never thought it would come
you've been lying to people for
fox news 20 six years
27 years i'm just like you've been
[ __ ] lying to people
not shading lying that somehow they
wouldn't
say that by well actually they called
they called for biden
early but they called arizona everybody
um
but uh they've been they
they just their whole it well actually
you know what fox news
watching that coverage was good until
laura ingram came on yeah and then
tucker was not good right but i they i
was watching the afternoon i
i once laura ingram came out i was like
okay it's over it was like she just
checked in
yeah she mentioned blm and antifa and
you know okay
that's all they do and the funny thing
is they don't and when i'm on the like
lurking conservative websites and stuff
they don't they don't think that those
people are part of them
like these are one-off outlook this is
not what we stand for you know but i'm
like this is exactly
what you said this is what do you say
you don't stand for winning elections
you cannot literally they couldn't win
so then they said well it was stolen no
you lost
yeah you lost that's it it's like the
olympic the 78
wasn't 76 or 72 were they munich
no that was a good one though that was
it will be will be wild
um the where the usa basketball team
beat russia and then russia was like oh
there was a mix-up with the clock
right and doug collins and a lot of the
teams still won't take the medal like
not [ __ ] it
so because they just lied and cheated so
you
you didn't win so then you say
oh well it's because a little democrats
cheated
no they didn't you [ __ ] lost and by
the way dumbass you lost
georgia because you said that yeah
you [ __ ] the video in the [ __ ]
voting system
is low amongst your side it is very high
all the pollings were so
drastic that it's like you're
[ __ ] yourself there's a there was a
sketch on mr show one of the great
sketches of all time
if you get a chance watch it it's great
um but there was a
like a there was a hip-hop there was
like a two summer camps
parody and there was one one guy
wrapped and then they cut to bob
odenkirk and he goes
like he lost the wrap out and goes his
science is too tight
um republican science is too tight yeah
they lit they just they [ __ ] them they
overdid it they
they played their hand they were they
they had the right amount of crazy
their recipe was good and then their
science got too tight and they
it so they lost georgia because their
size too tight and then they stormed the
capital because their size was too tight
and they lost
i gotta think they lost 15 million
voters
seeing the capital yeah like
15 million centrist voters centrist
uh you know mild right
center-right voters for like this is
[ __ ] or the ones that are
they believe like the conservatives that
are like america's sacred
uh federal buildings are sacred our
history is sacred yes
they were they were a little they were
they had indigestion
yes it was like [ __ ] i suppose
this is yeah that's not what i supported
but yes
this is where women need to step up i
can't
there were women there right no no but
there were i would
30 to one men to women in women's
in weird conservative like terrorist
loyalist defense
that was scary for a woman that was like
a real aggro involvement that's what i'm
saying
this is where women go oh i thought they
were protecting me
from antifa
turns out [ __ ] thinks that
i believe the reason trump won with
women
was because
that he made him feel unsafe he make
america literally american carnage right
yeah
um that's his that was his opening
number was american carnage
so women i think vote for conservatives
because they
feel like the world's not safe and they
need
mean gross men to protect them from
other mean gross men
and now i think i hope women see like
oh the mean gross men that i
was looking to for protection are
actually meaner and grosser than any
other
uh they band together and any other
group of [ __ ]
taliban and annie a mad i mean this
it's it's not even worth talking about
like imagine if all these people have
been blocked
so it's so obvious
yeah um they looked so
taliban-esque yeah hezbollah taliban
writing it
i'm just like y'all are the same they're
the same they slightly they just
it's all you know yeah i said white ice
white
they'd say vanilla isis and yeah that's
a [ __ ] sweet one that's like vanilla
isis
uh meal team six
is another good one they were so [ __ ]
nasty so this is where you go all right
women
so how bad do you think joe biden and
kamal harris are going to be
you know what i mean like what do you
think they're going to do
that's going to endanger you like how
black people have
never done anything like this
even like uh frederick douglass
or or um uh
who's homeboy who who they made the
movie about him birth of a nation
oh um oh yeah yeah not turner
is [ __ ] this is [ __ ] way worse
than matt turner
that turner was like 15 dudes yeah there
was no
this is not even like a rebellion in
wartime
but they think they're we are in war
they think we are in war right now
when it was happening and because they
were lied to
right by people like donald trump
rudy giuliani josh hawley ted cruz
lady g all the mitch mcconnell [ __ ]
and then hundreds of uh
house representatives yeah
but that so when i saw it online i was
going to go
to the flower market in dtla and i was
like
yeah there's going to be if you just get
a boyfriend and you wanted to bore the
[ __ ] out of him
that's like that i feel like that's
every la woman's
first awful chore that you have to do
with her like do you want to go to the
flower market
on saturday morning oh like [ __ ] first
of all
you know i don't like i don't like
company when i do girls do your [ __ ]
i'm like no i'm gonna feel bad like
shout out by the way to the person who
said that i
drank from a salad a bottle of salad
dressing
it's maybe one of the greatest slams
i've ever heard about myself people are
obsessed they were they love the arms
they love the arms out and they have no
idea
and they're really obsessed with your
water water bottle
it's a it's honeycomb it's a it's great
what is that
great bottles to be a big beautiful
bottle
um and when i saw that i was like nah
there's gonna be copycats i'm just
stating my ass inside yeah
lo and behold dtla they pulled her wig
off and maester that black lady who what
was that
they just had a because those people
what we're talking about is a woman
in la got held down and maced
so they had a copycat they had a copycat
um protest in at
our whatever in downtown l.a at the
capitol or whatever the hell is city
hall and
um there was just a group of trump
supporters or like loyalists
and i think they i heard they were
asking people like did you vote for
trump
as they're like people are watching a
loyalty test
no just like did you vote for trump and
then she's
i think she was like [ __ ] off like [ __ ]
you or something linda nebo
uh 25 said she was walking home near the
protest when she was harassed by some of
the demonstrators
i'm walking by and they're yelling at me
because of my color call me the n word
call me the b
word um
uh keith getting ready to throw up
keith's getting ready to throw up hey
buddy get down okay
[Music]
so i just cleaned up keith's puke and
one of the problems is um
when it he eats he's a street meat eater
but the problem is
his other favorite food is dog food
so it's what's the there's not that big
a difference
you know there's no regulation in to
actually what goes into dog food i was
gonna
always want to do a sketch about the um
quality control guy at a dog food
factory
where he's like nah yeah that's fine so
we found a finger
yeah yeah it's dark yeah [ __ ] there's
a
there's this have you ever seen my
strange addiction
uh i mean i know you get what it is a
lady was addicted to eating cat food
and she was like i graduated i graduated
she's like i graduated from
dry to wet and the doctor
you know they have segments of like
showing how weird you are the next one
is a family
more recently you know where you are
doctor and then recovery
and so uh the doctor was like
you know there's no regulation into what
they put into
animal food and a lot of the times it's
roadkill
like rotting roadkill they just put it
in boil and stuff and she was like
well i don't think that i mean i don't
know if that's what i've done
i remember when i was younger someone i
knew worked for
he said that they have to make dog food
edible for people
that's a [ __ ] lie well they don't no
one's ever
died from dog food do you know what i
mean but it's gross
off of dog food sure they do
are poor people live off dog food that
lady lived off cat food
she did no one's ever gotten dog food
poisoning or cat no
not poison no no in that sense yeah for
sure i just mean in terms of like
sustainability like well i don't sure
yeah it's a bridge meal
it's it's if you're thinking it's what
you eat until you get
to you know to a chicken feed okay
um so so she's walking so she's walking
home
in at downtown l.a downtown l.a where we
had the other protests yeah right there
and they cost her the caller [ __ ]
[ __ ] whatever mace her and
hold her down with her arms i saw it it
was so
it looked like it was a hundred years
ago and it looked like a movie it looks
staged
yeah like a bad movie yeah it wasn't no
and a lot of the that guy
that's seen holding her also her shirt's
tight um
the what's the shirt it's uh it's the
blunt wraps oh got it anyways no
backwards yeah
uh yeah that guy worked at a toyota
dealership and he's fired like a lot of
the people they could identify got fired
but that's
sick that's weird why are you grabbing
someone yeah it is
weird no i told all my friends to like
stay inside
and also um imagine how badly he's
ripping black people off at the toyota
dealership
and that's what i mean you think of this
crimes
in special rugs that he sold them
uh yeah it's just gross also the guy
anyone who looks like a white
supremacist
is what i hate to say it that bluntly
no one at no
no i've never seen a white supremacist
gone huh
that's surprising they all look [ __ ]
they all look
like like bearded like yakeda or they
look like
jared kushner josh holly like little
[ __ ] ghoulie
skinny prissy ghouls but i feel like
when you say child monster it's like
saying
child rapist like every ev she's like
yeah he looks like one
yeah but like as soon as you say it it
taints their face
yeah you could that guy could have been
a community
help teddy bear naked i mean he just
could you
you can't you
don't you know then you just you're you
have better
taste than to do have that kind of beard
okay but
i'm saying first of all he could be a
lights he could be a he could be a blake
no no he couldn't he's got a [ __ ]
amish beard dude
all i'm saying is that white
supremacists don't always look like
white supremacists
okay i i've never agreed
with anything you've ever said more okay
they always look like whites
they know it's never surprised that god
looks like a white supremacist
you don't wear a beard and your hat
backward you just know oh i look like a
white supremacist
i need to turn my head at the rally they
all look like white supremacist i'm just
saying
that but even his toyota dealer his
picture
as i'm sure we all looked up i did not
his toyota picture
looks like a white he just looks like a
[ __ ]
doughy white supremacist there's just
more people who
are white supremacists he looks like he
look and in his toyota picture he looks
like a white supremacist
at a job interview there you go that
looks like a white roy ball looks like a
white supremacist at a job interview
it's not like hey you used to be a
lineman no lineman no
he looks like a white supremacist it's
just like it you know
they always look like i'm never like i
said i'm not no one
in at the rally defied type no nobody at
the rally
not one person 10 000 people they all
look like they're in the right place
they were all auditioning for the same
yeah for the role of
traitors criminals okay um and they all
had the
bat those white they looked george
uh uh [ __ ] like
uh michael uh i remember
charlie murphy one time was talking
about he was in the navy and he goes
uh he he was talking about being the
navy he goes like he had a real white
name too
stringer yeah and i was like yeah that
is
that was before stringer belt right um
but his last name was stringer they all
have those three
white like dust powder white
right like andrew michael johnson
exactly
just like nope not black no nothing
middle easter nothing there's no
raheem's in there uh the all the
um just the people at the capitol though
were so massively uncool just on a
completely separate thing like the guy
with
who is an actor they couldn't even even
the way they yelled
was hacky like he nancy
come on out it's like oh [ __ ]
this writing is so bad would you rather
be in a room of them doing chants and
and uh
cheering each other on or watch split
[ __ ] well the splits always
write like that so i'd rather be with a
split
okay because at least the split goes
back to its normal personality
at some point um at some point um
you want to oh somebody said that a
funny uh
name for a segment on the show would be
a white cry for help
and this was the whitest cry for help in
the history of
white help this was stepson acting out
mad at his mom and this is weird it was
just strange
a strange emoting of it was
still it was it was people act it was
lucky here it was here it was lucky here
but more i think they thought it would
have landed a little better yeah well
because
this because they're
this is the thing i talked about a month
or two ago about like the national
enquirer
energy yeah
speak on it neil the the there is
too much information
there's the there's there it used to be
the funnel and the funnel was biased
usually a little left and i read that
book anti-social where they said
um this is that was it
was wrong but it's probably better
right than whatever this is people
cannot discern people are not discerning
enough
to deal with this much information
they're just not
they're not like the way we've lived
as human beings there was just a
mind there was a trickle of information
there was a trickle of like
and you'd get it from an elder or
somebody respectable
and even the newspaper was a hundred
years ago was like
like they always compare the internet to
like the printing press and stuff like
that
yes and no the printing press was
uh finite
like you could only print so much [ __ ]
and then
now this is infinite infinite printing
press
everyone's got their own printing press
right and unless
you are discerning which most people's
brains are not
that good just like usain bolt's the
fastest person in the world
and then there's that george ball
whatever that like there's people like
usain bolt
can run the 100 meters in 9.9 seconds
and then some people can't walk
okay they're too fat to walk right right
that's we've got the intellectual same
spectrum where there are people that
cannot can barely think can barely put
thoughts together
being bombarded with information and
they can't
take it if they [ __ ] oh you it's too
much
so you end up they go we're gonna storm
the castle
because they're stealing it from this
guy who loves me
he doesn't love you yeah he's lied to
you and you can't discern
a lie from the truth you can't discern
that this guy's [ __ ]
the biggest bullshitter in in
the the most successful bullshitter
maybe in world history yeah
like like i said at least hitler made
the trains run on time
hitler like you know what i mean like
there he there was
he's ineffective in every way right
there's nothing he's effective at
um and these people are too credulous
and dumb
to go like wait a minute did you hear
the
the audio of the woman calling that
c-span talk show
no crying no what'd she say she's like
did he lie to us no yeah
she's like she's realizing
that that basically he was lying
and and again you know i think
the first thought is i gotta call c-span
um that's it was a white cry for help
what was cracking me up was
the fact that these guys are so
queuing on deep like they're really
a total lie based on
one person with a printing press putting
out
yeah two guys in the philippines with
the producers
or yes or or whatever whatever
that's what i'm saying it's just just
random people
and it's convenient i don't even think
people realize what
q anon thinks about trump
i don't think they realize how [ __ ]
nuts they think he's
a savior to kill the
child monsters childlessness they think
he's saving
america from child molesters yes and
this is he's usually
he's using covid as a pause so we can
actually
pursue and convict and capture child
moles
yeah and they're so they're [ __ ]
deranged
and and again people can't even
take covet information correct i mean
they p
that's five g i heard someone say 5g the
other i'm like
five g the [ __ ] are you talking you
notice how that it
that whole 5g thing went away because it
was a [ __ ]
lie yeah because no company is in the
business of
killing people other than monsanto and a
few
but like they're not in the business of
death it's like they you can't survive
as in a business of killing people they
don't want to kill people they might
as like every once in a while
you know monsanto or exxon or whatever
and
kill some people and what are you gonna
do uh collateral damage i believe it's
called
um but they can't
the q anon thing is endless
it's like a it's like a it's like a
basically a role-playing game
that's set up for you to solve you
it's like then that you write fan
fiction about this
queue and it's endless and you can't
tell the people
it's the cult the debt the doomsday cult
[ __ ] where the guy said it's gonna the
world's gonna end on this date
it's like in the 60s or 70s didn't end
and he was like
that was a true test that's it's just
infinite
yes uh people cannot handle it it used
to be
national enquirer and it was all the fat
cats and the big wigs
right faculty and ben and and the you
know the
the haves and the have-nots and but and
now it's so
crazy i took a class in college that was
it was the only one i could take for
this one to satisfy this one credit
credit and it was in it was just about
antiquity so ancient greece ancient rome
and towards the end of it this is he was
some european guy maybe austrian so
forgive the
you know forgive us we're not by the
this is a very an exact podcast
oh yeah you've been very i think we've
been pretty clear about that yeah do not
hold us
yeah word just be cool don't write any
[ __ ]
q anon does is giving us great
information
so some of it's not exact but um so he
was saying
he's like you know i've studied ancient
greece in ancient rome for years my
most of my whole life and you look
at he's like the one thing i it's hard
for me to wrap my head around is how did
a
such an influential
society and community and and country
that
they were so influential and how the
[ __ ] did they become present-day greece
he's like present-day greece is
ignorant they're small-minded they're
close-minded their economy is
i mean i know about the economy it's
like in the sugar um
he's like i it's hard for me to
understand how they gave
us so much so much fantasy not even the
romans gave us
as much you know uh
just creativity and advancement in
progress
and he was just like a great first album
right greece had a
fire first album yeah
hits seriously and bad boy
and he's like and you go to greece now
and he's like there's
greece is so unremarkable the only thing
that's good about greece
is their history yes and that's it and
he said they're so ignorant
and they just they valued i mean
a lot of our politics a lot of our
policies a lot of our school
everything is really based on ancient
greece and then ancient rome
reinterpreted it and whatever
but um politics
everything they valued he concluded that
they valued intellectualism and they
valued
scientists and they valued progressives
and they valued people
pushing and new technology and
everything like that and then
it started to change where that was too
much and that got too far ahead of
themselves and and they it starts
meaning meaning the elect the
intellectualism the valuing
and um weighing intellectualism elitism
scientists progressive it it does
isolate
sometimes it can go isolated the country
no it can isolate a part of the
population that isn't keeping up but it
isn't
intelligent it's the thing i would say
it's the death of expertise that thing
where
people resent the guy who thinks he can
do stand up
exactly it's the it's the guy the the
the guy who thinks he knows better than
dr fauci the guy who thinks he knows
it's you know it it
they they do it in sports a little bit
but sports is so statistical and people
go well
it's like guys have the thing where if a
guy's better looking than them he's gay
and a lot of times they're right but
that's the thing it's like this guy's a
fur
yeah but they with intellectuals
you think you're better than me yeah and
they don't know they don't think of you
at all
no one's thinking about you you're not
special
you couldn't be less special all the
people that trump said is special
there you could not be less special
okay that's why trump's where he is and
where i'm where i am
i'm telling you you're not special
right i don't love you you're not
special
go home that would have been my that
would have been my message to the
protesters
do go home but but yeah that's the
they so resent the
like [ __ ] that guy yeah thinks he's
better no he doesn't think about you at
all i think he's burning me
yeah he's just doing it can't get in the
club yeah hating from outside the club
and so you think about like what i was
thinking about that when i was watching
the siege i was thinking about my
teacher
and what he said and
i do think there is a major consequence
going on in america for
that you know that grit between
weighing heavily on progress and being
number one
and you know being like advancements in
technology and being on the forefront of
things and also leaving behind a
part of the population that doesn't
value that same stuff i mean
there's a reason why like we say on here
they think
liberals are [ __ ] cuck simp ass
[ __ ] gay [ __ ] ass [ __ ] ass
yeah and yeah and they and they and
liberals think
and they think liberals think they're
better than them and they're right
liberals do think they're better than
you
right um and there's people those
there's people maybe they don't
agree with what happened to the capitol
but they would
much rather be associated with those
people than ever because they'd rather
lose with the insurrectionist criminals
than win with liberals
yeah with dr fauci then win with kamala
harris then win with obama
then win with aoc then went even though
they're they have so much more in common
with all those people
right uh they resent the fact that their
talent don't
don't really tell me what to do well how
about about science can i tell you what
to do about science
yeah yeah yeah did you ever see that
let's see uh that
insane clown posse no the other song
called miracles like they
they spoofed on snl but on it it's like
and i don't even want to talk about your
scientists
y'all [ __ ] lying and getting me
pissed oh that's so funny and it's so
funny and they it's like um i don't know
cruel intentions with ryan phillippe and
the of some other guy spoofs it it's i
know he's also understood but
threw it on the ground is it that thing
no okay they
they redo that exact music video and
they just make fun of
okay the two guys it's so [ __ ] funny
but people don't like
someone coming in they don't like
experts no
they're because it's like no i'm an
expert not about
this you're not i don't understand i
don't know
[ __ ] i'm having a guy come and build a
door
could i have figured it out neil
probably had a guy coming
what [ __ ] curtains now you know last
week i took
i took things in my own hand i got a
stud finder
oh wow did you put on yourself yeah i
and i qualified uh magnet hammer i ha
i hung something i hung that over there
that's been on the floor for
literally eight years a picture of mort
saul
um you can't say it okay um
uh i don't i i'm good i know what i know
i know the [ __ ] i know about and even on
here if we [ __ ] up people
correct us we go okay we literally have
a segment called we
gon apologize yeah no one does that by
the way just give us a little credit
by the way we're amazing can we tell you
about apologies
um no but no one wants to admit [ __ ] i
mean just
i don't know i know about comedy and
like
directing a little bit and uh
movies like writing
you know like structure but that's i
mean those are three things but
otherwise it's like the time i watched
basketball with blake
and he talked about he
he said something i go pause it tell me
what's happening
and he's like this guy should be here
this guy should have come up here
here here no idea what he's talking
about
he's still by the way the clippers are
two and eight is that good
no where he was like this is this
whatever i don't think it was both two
and eight two one two wins eight losses
oh um it's not good why what is that was
that a good thing they just don't have a
lot of talent what i thought they had
the
koami something that's
again kl kfkl nope
kiwami leroy
no they don't have anybody they blake
they have
jeremiah uh
yeah basically uh what happened to the
he has his name that sounds like hawaii
you said clippers kawhi leonard
yeah he's on the clippers i'm talking
about the clippers
i'm talking about the pistons you didn't
say the pistons you said the clippers
did i
yeah [ __ ] oh you listen here
i was like
like this is our year oh pistons are
houston or
detroit the team blake plays for it oh
okay what i'm saying is
as much as blake knows about basketball
oh they're they're they're still tuning
in okay
how are the clippers clippers are doing
pretty good okay
um so uh
yeah people resent expertise so much
because it's like
what are you saying i don't know you
come to my house
and yes i don't [ __ ] neil degrasse
tyson knows a
shitload about space i don't i don't
resent him
i'm not interested but i don't resent
him
i don't care i'm not interested i don't
give one i don't give a [ __ ]
but i i'm not like look at this
do you know like neil degrasse tyson
he's done
like what maybe a third of his life is
dedicated to just math and science
getting that knowledge you you win
you do you dedicated you dedicate a
portion of your life yeah to
gain knowledge yes so and they
but and but the problem is these people
have
[ __ ] feeble minimum strength brains
okay they just have minimum strength
they don't camp they can't
they literally thought if we storm the
capital
we're gonna stop the steel i i don't
even know what they're talking about
of course but let's just take it from
the
like loyalist insurrectionists and
zoom out to tens and tens of millions of
people who believe
trump who are yeah like
something something maybe they are like
you know maybe don't do all that but
let's just take it back from the like
the fringe cuckoos what do we say
to th those people are not especially
like
it's so bad i'm not sure i don't i
that's the thing is
i don't know what's like are we gonna
become i don't know
i truly don't know what the solution is
because if
everyone has a printing press yeah
and the audience can't discern
something actual from something because
the fact
the fact the the establishment
institutional fact places new york times
washington post
yeah whatever
are too resented to be believed for sure
because i remember rogan used to say
like well at the conor mcgregor fight
they said he was bleeding and he wasn't
i was like
okay the one guy [ __ ] up
and no one else could corroborate it
because the sports editor wasn't
watching the [ __ ] fight
i i don't see that that's an excuse to
doubt everything the new york times says
they [ __ ]
they write retractions they [ __ ] up on
the gulf war they said we [ __ ] up
um so
i don't know it's it what to me
the decision that needs to be made is by
intelligent people in the center and
intelligent people on the right
have to decide what
if they can give these [ __ ] these
[ __ ]
[ __ ] oxygen because
you can't because it parlor got shut
down
or what they can't get they can't get a
server they can't get a server
and then and and but that's what's got
to happen
yeah i mean i looked like there's a lot
of conservative
subreddits that are just blocked can't
access yeah
yeah because they're they're fomenting
lies
and violence i'm all for overthrowing
the government
if they're actually lying [ __ ]
go get them like all the all the gulf
war people should
have been tried in some way for like
especially like
you know um dick cheney and and uh
and scooter libby and all those
[ __ ] uh but
but this you you
were lied to because you can't discern
fact from fiction and you can't you have
so much resentment for
what is basically a beacon of
fact which is established
120 year old newspapers uh then what do
you think about them banning trump
because there's a lot of people saying
that's too far
it's just you can't yell fire in a movie
theater yeah
these people are yelling fire in a movie
theater i remember having this
discussion with with a friend of mine
and he was it was about alex jones
and he was saying how
uh you i think alex jones should be
allowed
because who decides
what's too far right i i don't
somebody's got to decide that's it i
mean that's the thing is because if
nobody decides
you end up with credulous people being
told
that they're that an election is being
stolen that's factually not correct
it's not correct it is not being stolen
the numbers were less than
one number was smaller than another
number
and they're somehow going like no it
wouldn't
no no check it again
and then locals they i mean they did so
much extra
work yes they had multiple elections
it's by the way it's the work is even
automatic
right it's if the margin is less than
five percent
or less than point five percent you
automatically check it
because there are balances in place that
that are [ __ ] helpful and fruitful
for a democracy you have to have facts
for democracy to work
um in germany
like the fallout from hitler was so
scarring that they drew their lines
in terms of free speech as well you
cannot
say anything racist you can't you can't
print anything racist even people who
are anti-nazis which is a huge movement
in germany when they put the circle with
a slash through it
for the swastika they
get in trouble because they still are
printing the straw with the swastika at
some point
yes they're happy even though it's about
antis
because at some point you right you draw
the sauce again there's a slash through
it
and so it's like you know they make
really specific rules
they make real they've defined free
speech as
it can go this far but past this
we have suffered it's consequences for
our freedoms right you can't be
free to lie on a
on a mass scale you yes you can't
you [ __ ] can't you can't deny the
holocaust in germany
no no you cannot you can't go in a way
yeah you could say it to a friend but
you can't but not
the wrong friend you can't print that
[ __ ] no yeah you say it
not the gestapo no you can't
there's they do they have done
i think here in this country we one most
people don't understand what free speech
is
two we think it's so
part of us that [ __ ] with free speech
feels
wrong well they but i think again the
first part
they don't they don't know they don't
know what it they don't even know that
you can't say
fire and incredible they're like okay no
you can't
free speech means you're not gonna face
government
government
cannot intervene you get fired you get
everything but everything but and the
funny thing is that's so powerful
if you've been outside of this country
it's so powerful to not
go to jail face any consequences
by from any government because of what
you said yes that's already so powerful
that like sorry you want no consequences
that's not
realistic yes what we have right now is
so i mean
i've been to iran and i
went to a museum and
you were stealing stuff no what the hell
oh
it's a rock i'm joking so story it's a
pr
that's a cost of freedom donald rumsfeld
freedom's met democracy is messy
and there's like a visitor book and the
there's like uh the clerics with the
kind of the really far right people are
called mullahs like yeah
slang term for them and i just wrote
[ __ ] mullahs because i thought that was
funny and i was a teenager
and i'm american and it's like i'm cute
he [ __ ] mula no i just otto warren
bockered it like it just you
don't realize yeah and i got in so much
trouble
and i did not realize that like i could
go to jail force
ever from writing i did what were we
doing
when i went to china when you got the
brain yeah
yeah but i just i'll repeat it
i was doing a joke about
they said like you're not supposed about
the three t's
uh tandem and square tibet and
taiwan just yeah
and i could this was right when the
uyghurs thing was happening
and i was and i said uh here's something
you guys don't hear a lot around here
assalamu
and a black american woman was
in the crowd in the front row and she
goes better go ahead with that [ __ ]
like quietly like she was like like
they'll wrap you up
i could have been wrapped up and gone to
jail
for saying no that's
not free speech that's that's not
that is that is uh whatever i don't even
know what the opposite of that's
not that's a
monitored speech that you can be
punished for that's what america doesn't
have but america
now needs limits on like a german
limits on what you can say in public and
if an
election wasn't stolen you can't [ __ ]
say it was
well hopefully they will pass some sort
of legislation to prevent a future
president from being able
to incite or just say lies i mean i but
then again politics there's so much
lying
that's kind of the point the bigger
issue to me is
it's it's um
it's the kellyanne conway alternative
facts thing
it's like no it was stolen
what are you talking about it wasn't but
yes it was we heard that
it may have been stolen that there there
was irregularities
and then that becomes real because
they're lying
right so i don't this is where you just
get into
i don't know what the solution is like
for example when he
did there's that protester where they
got him and they're like be nice to him
or something
and then i think someone i think he told
him roughing up
rough them up but be nice like a long
time ago like using trump yeah oh when
he was talking about
uh the cops putting people in police
cars no there was a there was an actual
protester there
i think maybe i'm [ __ ] this up but
basically the protester wanted to
sue donald trump because they punched
him
or something the people in the crowd
punched him yeah and he was like well
you told them
you you said yeah yeah and then
he was protected because he added be
nice
yeah so i think there's gonna well
that's the other thing trump is so
good at skirting the line it's
like this most obvious way but it's
amazing
it's another one of those things where
he's so good at it
it's he's the michael jordan of
hitler's um no he's that he's so [ __ ]
good
at at skirting the line
that it's very he knows what he just
knows how to be
suggested without being responsible he's
like i need you to find the votes come
on guys it's 11 000 votes come on what
he didn't say illegally he doesn't he
just keeps it vague so that it's not
prosecutable he's so he's that means
he's
been able he's worked on that skill for
a very long time since he was
a child that's like when you go on a
date with someone and you realize like
they got a lot of problems like this is
yes
so like good luck with all that yeah
like how old are you oh yeah you should
have dealt with this
yeah yeah too far gone yes
um but what it means for
i just don't understand how you on [ __ ]
our
how we unfuck ourselves they uh
introduce the the impeachment
yeah yeah oh today
yeah and they said that they actually
have the votes in terms of republicans
to
impeach him oh really but saying they
have the votes and actually having the
votes are different
it's like this is pretty close though
well yeah but saying like he said he
would like
the problem is all the senators
no republicans who who impeaches the
house
who peaches who tries house peaches
and senate tries yeah i don't yeah
so uh they all the senators are getting
voice mails
that are frightening like if you
impeach trump
it's like what the [ __ ] do you think is
gonna happen yeah what did you think if
you lied to a bunch of
armed morons was gonna happen
what the [ __ ] did you think was gonna
happen you can't control
you wouldn't have been able to control
they i was talking to somebody who was
like
so mike pence was the only thing keeping
us from
the country ending seriously mike pence
yeah
um and
the sis the system is [ __ ] the system
of government's [ __ ] up
and the system of media is [ __ ] up
because it's
it's the it's there's a prop of course
there's profit and lying
yeah who are you going to go with
someone who lies to you all the time or
someone who
flatters you and says you're beautiful
and we you're special and i love you
yeah
[ __ ] you're gonna go with the [ __ ]
liar
if i had the thought that if trump gets
it put in jail at some point
they will break them out like the old
west
like with like c4 on the side and
[ __ ]
oh yeah like file in the [ __ ] cage
you've never but that's the thing when
you
that the one thing i was surprised by
a lot of the time you see on social
media
videos of you know
like this is the this is the angle
they're not showing on the news
and you're like that is [ __ ] up but
usually no one
vets them or they're just a random cell
phone video these ones of the
the officers letting them in waving them
in everybody
is really interested in getting to
volume what the [ __ ] that was
the ones where they were just like oh
that one no the one
where they opened the barriers and then
waved
it it looked like black friday it looked
like a black friday sale
that's fun yeah at best buy it did
that's so funny yeah that's what it
looked like
it was weird yes uh it was black friday
for kill american senators
like that's what it looked like like it
was yeah
it's it's just so [ __ ]
disgusting and and again
the racism here are the interesting
racism angles
to me the
how when
white supremacists say [ __ ] on
even reddit it's protected speech
whereas if a bunch of
muslims from dearborn michigan said
we're going to storm the capital
or we're going to storm the state house
it somehow would have been a hate crime
flagged monster main flag beyond
knowing that everybody in your family
your whole shit's canceled your k your
wi-fi is getting cut off
what's weird is that uh the report air
purifier is not going to work
ain't purifying [ __ ] um it's weird that
the report came out saying so white
supremacy is the number one
threat to america yeah in democracy
and none of them are on a list well they
weren't
until until now but they're like help
help
internet help the fbi why if the number
one threat
is not islamic terrorism it is not you
know
black unrest or civil like civil unrest
with like racism if it's
white supremacy yes why isn't the number
one threat
why why is it a grassroots effort to
monitor these people why is the
grassroots effort to dox them
we are doxxing them they're the fbi's
like help me i'm sure they
they they have other things like cell
phone access
like the capital there's like a tower
that pings that everybody's there you
know whatever but
why didn't you know about these people a
lot of these people were high up
in q and on or really deep in and active
in
q anon and proud boys and three percent
all this [ __ ]
why aren't they terrorist organization
if it's the number one threat
well right it's also you want the refs
want them to win a little bit yeah they
want when you're like
these white supremacists and you're
white you're like
i mean i'll i'll look i'll look into it
but they're not [ __ ]
they're not doing it with the passion
for against
browns that they would have like they
that would be
like i stood up either [ __ ] they
don't have any of those yarn
diagrams for white supremacy because
they're just like well
ah you know they're not so bad it's your
cousin's
kind of a white supremacist if you're
white let's
follow mar let's just [ __ ]
tab martin luther king up the wazoo
because
i mean like he's preaching for peace yes
we
have to get to the bottom of it uh black
panthers just yes a bunch of just a few
dudes in oakland
literally everybody
everybody on the fbi but when you're
it's white supremacy is like
it's it's uh
they want them to win a little bit
they want them they that's it they
wanted to win a little bit they're just
because they
aren't preaching for anything that makes
it like a fifth grader
sweep there's not that good at it
or just any guy cleaning there's a
certain kind of guy that
like the military cleans correctly it
doesn't smell good but they
ammonia [ __ ] yeah it's like a bunch of
fifth graders sweeping
well because they're not reaching for
anything that disrupts their lives
correct yeah they're not they're not
going to take anything
from the fbi cia whatever right
but that's for now
this yeah no it's just come on it's not
gonna just be
all right now that it's just us whites
yeah
that's the yes then they'll get into
like well it's they saw them
the cops saw if you think they killed a
cop you don't think they'd killed josh
hawley
the cop was just white yeah they
[ __ ] because i was like is it was the
cop black or something and i looked it
up last night i was like
if they'll kill a white cop they'll kill
[ __ ] anybody they'd they'd
at least if they killed ted cruz they'd
be famous for it you know what i mean
like they'd be
right we'd all be like pose with a body
like like uh
osama bin laden yeah exactly like they'd
be excited to get
they it would be cool by the way i love
that
all these guys are going to get caught
because
they were too dumb to wear a mask the
one time you
want to wear them they won't even wear a
mask during crime
you [ __ ] morons and
they thought it was cool content oh they
couldn't not broadcast they couldn't
they needed fame
yeah again you're not better than me
talented attractive person i can make
i can make content also here it is
it's all it's just me incriminating
myself
but it's it's it's guys on the ground
with [ __ ]
that guys on the with the money just
[ __ ]
dumb guys who grant he'll it's basically
to now it's been dumb
uh young black dude stunting on the gram
and
confessing to crimes and that's now it's
[ __ ]
old white dudes stunting on the ground
and the stunt uh went wrong there was a
bad the ramp
busted it was the space shuttle
what was the the guy with the horns he
even after being arrested and having
charged president he gave an interview
saying
you know what's the most hurtful thing
is that people keep calling me antifa
like i'm not anticipating oh i
they still want the credit that i
actually respect i
i was the bad part i was apparently that
guy complained today his mom said that
he hasn't eaten because he they won't
give him organic food
wow i'm the cockpit yeah okay he
also is a uh actor
voiceover actor in phoenix he's he's
[ __ ]
um the what's the
the ata aliens
um the art of speculating if he saw you
he'd be like
yo i love this javelina of course they
love
date i mean you know what i mean like
that's a whole other issue
okay the issue is if they kill a white
cop
who won't they kill so
anyone who's fomenting this even if you
think that you'll somehow be spared it's
just a
it's just a matter of opportunity even
by being in the senate you're putting a
mark on your chest
yeah because they don't get it they
don't get secret service
you know what i mean like they don't get
[ __ ]
[Music]
i don't know what aoc security's like
but it's probably not as robust as it
i'd like it to be i think it's more
robust than you think i think she
probably gets a lot of
nasty i'm sure she gets death
like more death threats than not so
they're saying that
they're the problem with
taking a lot of conservative like taking
the
platforms away from conservatives is now
it gets just into a darker corner well
that's
well again this is i have this down on
the sheet oh
the
the the the um so now it'll go to
we want we love encrypted chats we love
wechat we love
actually wechat's not it's chinese so
yeah chinese i mean i have webshop
the opposite of encrypting um uh
signal yeah signal whatsapp right
and and uh and and that we like it
apple is encrypted
texts tax on apple are encrypted
they can't if there's a criminal apple
will not help the
the government on de-encrypt your chats
right
um which is cool
in theory and this is again this to the
same thing
how much freedom before they're
storming the capital right it's how much
freedom do you want how
how tight do you want the science
because
it's cool but they so these guys were on
i mean they're
[ __ ] too most of them did it on
parlor which is not encrypted it's a
right it's a platform but but there are
some of it was on whatsapp and they're
not gonna be able to
open that you know what i mean like
they're not gonna be able to prosecute
these people
because of encryption
i'm for some limits
i don't again i'm selective about it
but i'm and i'm a hi i'm sure there's
hypocrisy like up
one step into it but there's got to be
some limits
because people are too [ __ ] dumb
and money's too good in lying
it's too you just [ __ ] it's too fox
made so much money off just straight up
line um
so why wouldn't and then so they're now
they're their lies aren't good enough
so now owen is gonna make kills newsmax
yeah
and at a certain point there's just
gotta be like ah
this i don't know what the i don't know
if there's
well do we hold the media companies to
a standard or do we hold politicians to
a standard i was like there's all the
mine
there has to be you can't
lie but they literally in the in the
laura ingraham's a [ __ ] liar they can
say it's
it's opinion but that's people don't
know it's opinion
they don't know that [ __ ] at five
o'clock
it changes from
uh it just becomes like a speakeasy or
something yeah it just becomes
the only time there's news is it like 3
a.m yes it's three
no 3m is infomercials there's news
the yeah the like the five isn't really
news
five is [ __ ] weird
whatever the morning one is right
really new yeah it isn't news no the
news isn't like 4am
there's news on fox the way there used
to be
shows for black people on networks were
they
like [ __ ] three in the morning and
like showtime of the apollo would be on
because they literally had to put it on
they had to have black programming
um that's what news is like on fox we're
like ah
we're only here to keep our license
alive and
they're just i'm sorry there have to be
limits because
people are too dumb they're just too
[ __ ] dumb
there's too many intellectual
comorbidities for people to
be exposed to infinite information
and i'm sh and people whatever not like
anything but the problem is with
media companies i mean there's literally
they go from
an actual story and then they go to the
spin room
so it's it's it's ingrained in it
everyone takes
goes from i don't know like uh
the white house press secretary to the
spin room
and spins it for their network so
how do it's called the spin how do we
change something where it's so ingrained
in it i don't know how there's
i don't know i mean honestly i do not
know it doesn't seem i don't know
possible
i mean i you kind of got this idea that
you
there needs to be like a supreme court
of truth
but how you staff that seriously
no [ __ ] idea like there it used to be
called science
but no no not even science is double
blind studies no i'm saying even that
somehow we can find scientists who
disagree
like you can find right a study yes
because sometimes it's it's an
interpretation sometimes studies need to
be interpreted
and that's where you get into like okay
well i don't i guess we just annihilate
ourselves
i don't see where else this goes but
annihilation i don't even think it'll be
nuclear war if it'll be nuclear where
it's from lie it'll be from this kind of
well you said yeah we're gonna we just
become greece that's kind of what
happens
some we'd be lucky to be grace we'd be
really lucky i mean i
like i said last week if we make it it's
not gonna be by much that's a classic
case
of like you [ __ ] didn't know
not to there was a weird thing
in
when they were in the senate chambers
they were almost less excited they were
that there was nothing there
[Music]
it was like supermarket sweep and then
they got there and they're like i don't
want this much
food i don't even it was it was just
like ah
they got a weirdo and then they get in
there and they thought there would be
like
kitty porn in the desks these [ __ ]
imbeciles
it was i went to like there was these
museums quote unquote that popped up
that were just
photo ops you know like museum of ice
cream
yeah yeah some 29 rooms yeah whatever
i went with a friend and they were
they're terrible but they're just like
you know oh something sparkly take a
picture in front of a big blanket
um it kind of looked like that because
they're like okay well let's
get a photo of me doing this yeah you
know there was no urgency because
there was no police so there's really
nothing to fight against
and then there was nothing to discover
no so they were just
that's when you get to i don't even like
people go like can you believe you're
performing at the so-and-so
radio city right beautiful but i'm not
like
i'm part of a lineage it's a [ __ ]
room
i
ultimately it's human beings in a room
and that's the thing of
what i was saying about conspiracy
theorists they've never
been anywhere yeah they don't know any
successful people
so they you ever have a friend who talks
so much about somebody
and then you meet them or they'll like
this person's such a piece of [ __ ] yeah
then you meet them nice they're not
remarkable in any way yeah like that's
how it looked
where it was it was black friday
and they and then they realized like did
i need a 38 inch flat screen that bad
did i punch that lady was it worth this
[ __ ] this here you go i'm holding up
a monitor
was it worth punching the lady for a
super
super super sonic monitor um
um you know what i it almost felt like
especially when you see
the uh the congressmen and women's
offices being strewn about with like
papers and stuff
it looked like they had watched the
joker too many times or watched
this i had that thought today i thought
where it's going to be like yeah
prince soundtrack's going to be playing
yeah
it's not the same without slow-mo huh
without that cool slime i actually had
that thought
today i can't believe more people
haven't tried to blame the joker
yeah i thought i was like they watched
the joke in two minutes
so many times not nearly as romantic as
you yeah they're all the people that are
like
yeah they're people jumping on cars who
are just
[ __ ] zeros who are not
special and i don't love you
i cannot say enough the anti
the six million wasn't enough so that's
so
gross the proud boys shirt that says
at 6 mwe meaning like 6 million jews was
enough jesus to die
i can't believe it's like who's selling
this bad merch what
for like what and then what
so you kill jews and then what
do you think that's like
yeah like now we can really enjoy earth
now that the jews are gone nobody's
gonna control the media
like what do you think that's what i
mean it's just
people trying to make a living most of
the time
bill gates isn't evil he's not trying to
implant you with a [ __ ] chip
somebody made the observation that no
somebody on that video i sent you a guy
saying like
the chip in your phone is what's going
to get you [ __ ]
because it's there's the beacons and the
wi-fi and
and it's like so bill gates did get you
just not the way you thought buddy um
whoops small world uh
yeah i i'm i i'm
i'm disgus i'm disgusted it's the wrong
word i'm like
even as a cynic it wasn't
there are certain things that i'm
cynical about and and that i'm
that get confirmed and i'm like see this
is so [ __ ] hard it doesn't even feel
fun to be like well it's really harmful
it's like i don't want cops to be killed
i don't want
congress people to be killed i don't but
but i i can't say enough
if they killed a white cop who won't
they kill
they didn't kill the black cop
surprisingly that was running
right so there's a black couple they
didn't think they could catch him
that honestly i mean i'm kidding and no
he's
the guy looked pretty spry did he yeah i
mean he looks bry if you're white
he was pretty close but he all he had
was a baton yeah so he led them on a
wild goose chase
away from the congressman yeah and he's
alive thank god
but he's gonna get a dollar raise
seriously
congratulations you're here's a nickel
um
but yeah i there's something about it
that
it doesn't you know it looked so easy
and even though a lot of people did
condemn it on both sides
it doesn't feel like it's almost like
you remember
the first time i don't know if you've
ever stolen but i the first time i stole
when i was like 13 or 14 i couldn't
believe it was that easy
yeah i couldn't believe no
and then that's when i realized oh we're
all on an honor system
everybody can steal if we all wanted to
but we're just
that book sapiens is basically like
these are all just agreed to myths
come money totally made up
made up double totally made double
yellow line in the road
yeah you're just assuming like what
come on it's i couldn't believe how easy
it was to seal
and then i did it two times and then my
friend got caught i didn't and i was
like yeah
[ __ ] wait there are [ __ ] consequences
just feeling
but i think we don't we're not seeing
the cause again
of course we we think that they're going
to go to jail but i just i have a
feeling this is the beginning of
something and not
oh man this has gotten really bad this
is the worst
you know i feel like this feels i don't
know i
don't know i i'm counting on
centrists and women well they're saying
that there's talk of one on 16th the
17th and the 20th
a nationwide capital all it's going to
take is
one sniper just going at meaning
world war z with the [ __ ] just people
getting mowed down
just mow just mow do like
20 seconds of mowing yeah
not even however long that was seven
seconds but now okay but
we're not talking about blm or you know
protesting
i'm talking about go up on the roof
of the capitol at the next
supposed rally have them ha
let one group do this do the do the do
the black friday
have them run down and just mow them oh
yeah that'll take care of it but but for
example
but the problem is that they don't
want to they don't i don't want to go
against them i know they
don't understand they will kill
anybody they will that guy
that one the cop that they killed
wasn't liberal no most of these cops
yes he was not a liberal he was
a conservative who was
trying to uh
to disempower
more conservative people and that's what
i'm talking about it's talking about
like
well what do you what do you think's
gonna happen
honestly what do you think's gonna
happen it's gonna [ __ ]
it's either whose side are you on you're
either on the side of civilization
which is means expertise and losing
elections sometimes
or you're on the side of if we lose we
we'd say it was stolen from us and then
we stormed the capitol
there's really no in between
they were killed so so it's
though it's the people that gave trump a
chance
like well maybe yeah no this can be
go really [ __ ] wrong but also one
thing i realized by listening to the
cell phone budget and stuff they
they think they own that [ __ ] like
you're
my police yeah well they're not wrong
technically it is all of our houses
but they think that they don't they
think uh
they identify that the police that
because they've they're on the police's
side that they shouldn't be policed
well what they're not saying is like
well we all hate
the blacks right right it's like not me
yeah
so damn yeah like give me taxes like if
you ever hear a black people go into our
house and
wipe your life okay that's cute
uh it's just it's i don't i think the
moment
i don't know i just don't i do wonder
how a white
against white plays out
this is where you just have to go am i
for a skin color or my fourth principle
yeah it's and it's going to be a tight
one
that's going to be a [ __ ] that's
going to be some that science
speaking of too tight science oh you're
scientists yeah this
science is too tight uh it will be too
tight science
and with a two the letter two
um and it's gonna come down to
[Music]
what are you for i mean honestly it's
truly like a reckoning of
what they killed a white cop
they'll kill [ __ ] anybody
who's who's in the wrong place at the
wrong time they are worse that it's the
the thing i i don't know when i said
this but apparently i said
white people imagine problems
that black people actually have yeah and
that's this it's like
so you think black people are going to
do that blind people just
they're [ __ ] doing that [ __ ] and like
insurance like come on man
um i got [ __ ] i got my girl buddy is
going to
storm the capital and think you know
we'll do
we'll [ __ ] we'll show them yeah we'll
storm
i mean now having said that the black
panthers did follow
cops which is close that's their version
right right
that's that's
not a bad that's just like taking
america at its word of like well i'm
allowed to watch cops yeah
and by the way and then they had
automatic weapons and then they just
change the laws
of course um yeah so um
so uh it's
you know it's the fear that what white
people think black people are gonna do
white people are actually going to do it
they're actually
just going to wantonly kill cops and run
up into the senate
and ooga booga it's white
it's uh it's white oge booga it's such a
it's it's
like a netflix series that had all the
potential it's
but it's a little bit worse than
designated survivor
it's so it's bad writing you wouldn't
believe it if someone came with the
script
that said and then they stormed the
capital
and they're wearing fur and it's just
like cheesy no
that's yeah no well because they always
do it it's always paramilitary and yeah
it's like
and it's always sexier yeah exactly so
this is just a bunch of
[ __ ] imbeciles always experts always
have fun
they're not illiterate but they're
illiterate adjacent these people
that's the problem whenever we have
people storming
something or outsmarting or you know
whatever
making it through like a barricade it's
like have you seen lupin
it's always just like a sexy dude that
outsmarted
a system it's never dumb [ __ ]
who are smartest
it's never just people who
str broke a window and then got into
like the capitol building it's so
awesome well that's the thing of the
intelligence thing
it's like bad it's very difficult for
white people didn't know what to do
about white terrorists
white law enforcement didn't understand
i understand
half of the i mean not half the cops or
half of law enforcement
are white supremacists but like they're
adjacent
i mean i don't know they're white they
prefer it
i don't even think the kkk is classified
as a terrorist organization
i i can't remember if that's true or not
it's one of those things where like i've
heard it and i can't remember what the
answer is
right so this country is always playing
throwing underhand with
white terror klu klux act
what what year is it say that they're
terrible no they know trump vowed to
designate the kids
still not terrorists yeah yeah meanwhile
they
only stood up they only stood for
terrorism
they only stood for terrorism so we've
been like america plays
you know softball underhand with white
supremacy so yeah
and that's the thing it's like what do
you what do you
what if you coddle these people
what do you think you gotta lock your
[ __ ] cousin up
unfortunately sorry sorry mate
it's like law order until yeah no for
everybody
law and order for everybody not daryl
yes fat red beard daryl
has it also got to go away toyota
boy boy he's that toyota's down another
one
damn it y'all yeah um so
black people have real problems white
people have
largely imaginary problems that get
get fomented into realer than real
more this is existential equal
or greater value yeah like that guy
didn't realize like
you black person can't drive with
[ __ ] napalm
to any like napalm
like you're not gonna see if like black
dudes are not gonna be
homemade oh my god that's frightening
he got it off amazon um no like
nate just the level of white
you know how much of a privilege it is
to drive around with napalm
that's probably the ultimate white
privilege is driving around with napalm
and not even worrying about getting
caught
do you know what i mean like i don't
think he was paranoid no he was just
killing everybody and [ __ ]
i got nate literally i got napalm
like brothers are not going to text i
got napoleon like [ __ ]
well napalm might be code for right now
very fun
right it's exactly but it's not they're
not going to even call it
so so yeah that's the white people enjoy
your privilege
it seemed thought out but so clumsy at
the same time
because someone made maps someone made
name palm someone but you don't
napalm's not a you know i mean there was
pre-medicine it's not it wasn't like a
covered thing where some people were
baking and other people were making
napalm napalm
it takes a while i mean that there was
premeditation
i don't think he knew it was for this i
think he just wanted
folks he just rides around with nathan i
know i just think he made napalm
for the revolution i don't think it was
for january 6th
2021 it was just generally having napalm
right but there was people that bought
zip ties that they had
i believe they have all this [ __ ] and
they they're
they're preppers meaning it's the same
way i have a bunch of ayahuasca [ __ ] now
i got a chair i got some maracas
i got okay i got a thermos got my white
you got to wear all white at one of my
camps i got all white sw
sweaters sweatpants it's cute you cute
cute boy
um so yeah it's just a [ __ ]
this another one i wanted oh and then
corporations are now
oh i love how they act like they have
they're taking a stand corporations are
not
donating to any republicans that that
we're trying to stop this deal but
by the way they also just said like
we're not donating to any politicians
why are you punishing liberals what what
did they
what the [ __ ] did they do yeah this is
you're late so everyone's gotta run laps
the [ __ ]
one people cry it's not fair
it's not fair you didn't do that with
blm in the summer then yeah
you know it's always like it's not fair
so right
because there's no truth yeah you can't
go well
george floyd actually died brianna
taylor
actually died wasn't i just got
back from brianna taylor's right they
weren't
there's not secret video of her like
walking to the
mailbox not with poc two bucks
two bug island yeah is alive and he's
getting ready to drop some [ __ ]
um so here's the thought i had about
narcissism
that i would like to get in public they
have the disease
you have the side effects that's that
that's this writ large it's trump's the
diseased person
and everyone else has to live with the
side effects he's fine
he's going to be fine it's every
narcissist ever
they are sick you're
the person who has to suffer the
consequences you got to cut it off
over and over and over and over and
but they're charismatic and people love
them some charisma
that was another one i wrote down there
was a thing last night
the kid who uh called me by your name
the actor army hammer army hammer
apparently is like into
cannibalism the the the tweets but maybe
it's made up i don't [ __ ] know i mean
i heard him did you hear him
talk about it and how he's embarrassed
no what did he say
he's like yeah sometimes if you're
saying a bunch of [ __ ] in the heated
moment
that sounds so perfect in the heat of
the moment
yeah and uh you hear them outside
of the heat of the moment it's extremely
embarrassing yeah
i yes but these are weird and he did
describe these as
[ __ ] perfect in the moment yeah but
here's the other thing read them
they're not oh my god
that just made me so hard and it makes
me confused as to why
is it that impossible so hard think of
holding your heart in my hand and
controlling it
controlling when it beats okay
that sounds like one of those relaxation
sponges
i'm a hundred percent a cannibal
that sounds like something delia would
have said jokingly
uh i want to eat you [ __ ] that's scary
to admit b
i've never admitted that before i've cut
the heart out of a living animal before
and eaten while i was still warm
um this is where you get into like yeah
buddy's good looking
so oh yeah all the fans were worried
girls being like yeah it's
yeah it's buddy but yes so it's fine
because he's good like
these people are [ __ ] bad
people can we please judge people by are
you
equating here it's kind of the same
thing it's this
it's an appealing guy yeah bull i mean
what's the difference between that and i
love you you're so you're very special
it's all the same [ __ ] thing it's
just charismatic people
people don't care what they're actually
like yeah
seem nice seem nice be good looking
that's the ultimate life hack be good
looking be tall and be
forget it and he's rich be tall rich and
good looking
write your own ticket enjoy that flower
that baking soda money
um that motherfucker's got baking soda
money he's a billionaire
um he doesn't and uh
kim and kanye met get divorced that
seems kind of pa that kind of pales this
week
i know that's the problem is that
started and it the rumor
this is rumor mill y'all but
apparently he's he got caught cheating
with
a male makeup
uh uh reviewer a youtube makeover named
jeffree star
oh he that mother that guy gets a lot of
guys around a lot yeah
he's dramatic he's a messy he's a messy
little queen
he's he's a little messy yeah so uh
so i guess you know on tick tock they
start they do these
you know 30 second breakdowns but
basically jeffree star
moved down the street in the summer to
in wyoming
and then kenny's been at the wyoming
ranch this summer
and then there's all this other you know
not real evidence but it's it's a little
like huh
okay that they but jeffrey were they
near each other
yeah down the street from each other and
their friends
i thought john didn't you say connie was
in wyoming and jeffree star moved to
wyoming oh i don't know down the street
i thought it was
from kanye
i don't know what i don't want to live
in any of these [ __ ] places i don't
want to live in calabasas
it's like have you never lived in
california
have you he grew up in chicago so he
doesn't understand like
do you not understand how [ __ ] awful
the suburbs are
they suck calabasas thousand oaks
woodland hills
they're so far away why would i think it
sounds
cool because all these famous people
live there they're
drive there go ahead go so bad
i'll wait and it's gonna be an hour it's
during covet it's an hour it's the
celebrities and persian people
yeah and i love my persian people but
yes i no one wants to live
in calabasas people i don't get when
people think they made it when they live
in calabasas
like yeah why would you ever i mean
people like land
is the problem it's like why they move
but they're not even unique houses
there's couldn't be less unique they're
outlet mall looking houses they all look
like california outlets
yeah they're mcmansions anyways
but yeah so um rumor is that he
jeffree star and kanye west hooked up
and kim's divorcing him
because of it i don't know why i i'm i
have no doubt that they will get
divorced
i don't think it's because of that i
mean no i'm sure they'll get divorced
but
i'm betting the bipolar has something to
do with it
again shot in the dark call me crazy i'm
betting the
constant constant nonsense because he's
sick and won't
and goes in and out of taking his meds i
would be
terrified to divorce him just because he
will just air out your dirty lines yeah
yeah but you can get an nda however he
wasn't allowed to
yeah not crazy but someone who's like
yeah if they go to jail
that they'll stop talking about it
howard stern had it howard stern
cannot talk about his first wife really
cannot
then doesn't doesn't howard certainly
doesn't have
isn't it correct um then he'll just get
fined
whatever the thing and maybe he'll go to
jail
and yeah because my friend's
boyfriend's brother's bipolar and one
time he was having an episode and
um i think in the shovel was like why
are yelling at me to like their mom like
why are you at me
he's the one and then just started like
like
rattling off truth and she was like
oh [ __ ] yeah that wasn't a lie
that was just something you shouldn't
have said mm-hmm so i don't know
i would be annoyed it would be a little
bit like some of it's fantastic and some
of it's
absolutely true some of it's hyperbole
some of it's a episode and some of it's
just
i let me cause a little mayhem
i like mischief everyone's gonna be
bipolar today
yeah uh having said that
it's kanye as a figure of this
i'm like like this [ __ ] and then i
forget i know him a little
and he's incredibly sweet every time i
see him
and i like have warm feelings for him
he's in like i don't have i personally
like him i don't have his number or
anything but i
i don't also but then when it becomes a
tv show then it's
yeah it's like what am i supposed to you
know i've never
well but speaking of tv shows the tiger
woodstock on hbo
what what [ __ ] good
really like next level
damn near transcendent maybe better than
bg's doc
but not oj no okay
no but there's more
there's so much more it's because the
guy's
been totally opaque it's you don't
people know nothing about him yeah but
there's really good
old footage that like his ex in high
school and college had
and there's information about his dad
that he kind of didn't know there's
there's
he was i said on twitter that he was
he's in some ways more like michael
jackson than michael jordan
in that he was really pressured
to play golf like [ __ ] really
pressured and there's an interview where
he's like
doesn't want to be there he literally
says i want to go poopy
no oh i thought you went as an adult no
no no i'm talking about
two three four
damn yeah which you don't of course but
they
they made it seem like oh this is all
him
it's joe jackson it's just like practice
your
[ __ ] michael spin spin spin spin
and with and eventually he not like he
grew to love golf he's [ __ ] amazing
at it but
but it's uh
you'll you'll really empathize with the
guy it's sad it's
you know it's the
people that are great who's it talking
to
people that are great don't have
balanced lives yeah
it's not it's not balanced it's not you
know michael jordan was not
balanced [ __ ] competition
all the time yeah uh even as a kid he
[ __ ] practice right like you don't if
you're successful it's not from being
moderate you're it's it that's
extremity breeds success that's it yeah
and this it's
it's it's uh set
and great and the
ending of the first part is [ __ ] very
funny
it's very funny how many parts two that
i know of so far
yeah i think it'll only be two but maybe
three um no i think it's just two
um but the ending it's like a it's like
a
um it's a it's like uh
in the on the next tiger woods and they
introduced
uh it's the yeah it's the it's it's more
like
well well what it's like putting the
gloves on
close up for the sequel like it's
[ __ ] sweet that's all i'm gonna say
okay bianca's fading everyone
no no no i'm not um i'm
not all right this is i almost don't
want to do email
because this is a because it's just
heavy it's just a lot
of one note not like i don't want to
break the note but
yeah but i just feel like let two hours
be
i think so what we did and because it
just
is such a i don't know
it's like imagine if we were doing the
uh the podcast during 9 11 and then
we talked about it and then it's like my
girl my girl
punched me in the dick whoa
whoa it's gross whoa
your dick um
yeah yeah so white
i don't think there's any white p i
don't think there's any white people
with any doubts
listen to the podcast about whose side
they're on
but in some ways the
same way that that i was saying that
white people when it comes to wokeness
i don't know if i said in the pockets
it's the it's the
air it's the airplane we need four
volunteers
how many white people are going to get
up to help black people yeah
right and give up their seat for black
people have you ever given up you see
i mean what do you mean like have i ever
for the bonus
yeah i want to say yeah but i don't
remember
oh you know i love a voucher that's
almost the perfect
analogy for white people in wokeness
like have you ever stuck up for a black
person oh no
i want to say of course that's what i'm
saying yes but i don't remember
yeah i feel like i have i carry myself
like
actually helps i've actually made
sacrifice for black people but that is
it's like give you we need four
volunteers who's
willing to make their life worse to make
a black person's life
better yeah i i mean
again i recommend black people for jobs
all the time
and i have been offered things and to
like hire a black person
not that often though like sometime a
couple times but not like
that's so much more than just people
yeah which i'm not necessarily patting
you on the back i'm just saying well
too late i took it no i'm just i took
the pants no
no give me my pants give me my pats give
me my pet
we'll play the song
[Music]
the fact that you foregoing an
opportunity to give to someone else
just simply based on the fact that they
might not get that opportunity is more
than a lot of people do for anybody
just in general but now there's a new
version of it which is
are you willing to turn a white person
in
paddle you gonna tattle on a white
yeah on your cousin because the thing is
too and this may this is maybe junk
science but
i do think people can have more sympathy
when you look like my cousin you look
like my mom you look like my
you know yeah and i don't have any asian
people in my family i don't have any
black people in my family
or middle eastern people my family so
and maybe that's
not a thing maybe i'm making that up but
i do think there's a weird
it's hard for white people to go against
white people
on the level we're talking about yeah i
don't think there's some huge white
solidarity it's not i mean i don't know
i don't giving paddling per se if
you know the guy who's in some of these
videos and you go like
i guess it is an ex-wife an ex-wife oh
they're
better they come on ex-wives if those
kids are of age you are
[ __ ] you are so getting popped
by your ex-wife what's that there's that
one um
there's that one joke [ __ ] who does it
where he says
uh if a black guy sees
if a white guy is beating a black guy
and a random black guy walks by he helps
the black guy
but he said if a white guy if a black
guy is beating up a white guy
and i walk by and give a [ __ ] about that
white guy who said that it sounds like
ian
no no it's not it's a white person it's
um tash maybe
no [ __ ] i hate not giving up no you're
getting closer
bret no bert it's no i don't
i don't know i'm not sure but anyways he
was talking about how
i don't give two [ __ ] what that white
person's doing like there isn't that
much
white solidarity like we we think you
know there are it is yes
there is there i mean do i am i loyal to
white people
no no am i loyal
would i be loyal to my cousin if i was
like kind of a little bit republican
and they were very republican
that's where it's that's where that's
where the rubber is gonna that's the
thing that's gonna be the difference
between
tyranny or between anarchy whatever the
[ __ ] they were going for
yeah um and a civil i don't truly don't
even know what they were they don't know
what they were doing they were stopping
the steal
what do you mean sir i wish there was a
reporter like what do you mean what does
that mean
what does that mean they don't know
they're just like well
um would you turn in your niece
for what for if you saw the capitol
and they were like identify this person
and no one else in your family was
gonna turn around yeah damn neil really
i don't i'm which kind of dick do you
want me to be like that's the question
that's my first it's like i can't if i
say no
then i'm a coward and if i say yes i'm a
coward
this is what i was saying about the girl
who uh
just if i can grind an axe yeah with
um when you were saying like i'm i was a
[ __ ] for not telling me oh i knew you'd
bring that up again yeah i was a [ __ ]
i'm telling my girlfriend to shut up
whatever the [ __ ] i was supposed to do
there was video of austin rivers
uh the basketball player came home from
a road trip
and his girl was any videotaped which is
hilarious and posted on instagram
of his girl getting mad because he had
to go to practice
where it's like how do you think i
afford any of
it's from practice yeah but not what
about
me yeah and she literally was like me
yeah
um because and but when when it comes
time for the
settlement she's going to want half yeah
so what who's the [ __ ] bianca that
didn't prove
anything neil yes it did it just proved
that that there is no standard for
women want attention and they want money
for half the thing that you did
that they hate that they argued against
that they didn't want you to do they
called you a [ __ ] because
a [ __ ] told you to go get an office
outside of your own house
and you did right but if i didn't i
would have been the guy
who was like [ __ ] you [ __ ] i'm not
getting an office
even though you said there's this
apartment this
town house is one room no what i said
was i understand
why she would suggest it i don't think
it's
her being like insane with demands but
what do you think her friends would have
said
if i was like no i don't give a [ __ ] go
outside
i would have i think the audacity to
tell someone i can understand the
annoyance
but i also when you're on the phone and
we're waiting i go on your rooftop and i
sit
i've done it multiple times of course
but that's ten minutes
and we don't live together my point is
i'm just saying that i think
there's some audacity yes that's crazy
[ __ ] the
lady with austin rivers is [ __ ] the
audacity of hope
the order so was my ex it was audacious
yeah it's very it's it
but as a guy it's be a dick or a [ __ ]
what do you want to be you want to be a
[ __ ] [ __ ] or you want to be a
[ __ ] [ __ ]
and you're playing into that narrative
you i knew you were yeah cause it's
[ __ ]
rude you're upset it's rude and it's
totally
un you're not holding yourself to any
consistency you're not because you
complain about women making demands on
men you complained but you you gave in
so what am i because i don't have but
you could just be like
guys have no recourse especially
woke guys have no recourse i don't
understand why
you couldn't just say you know what if
you agreed
then what the [ __ ] then null and void
but if you brought it up in a
way where it was an axa grind and you're
just like yeah i had a girl and she
just say no but then i'm an [ __ ]
she's the [ __ ] for what you didn't
say was that girl's a [ __ ] [ __ ]
for asking
that was that was the theme of what we
were saying
you're a [ __ ] you said i said you're a
[ __ ] yes but you didn't say
that girl's a [ __ ] ass that austin
rivers girlfriend is a [ __ ] [ __ ]
and so was the girl that told you but in
our conversation
in the conversation about your ex the
theme was
that's crazy that uh
people think they can like tell people
to do overstep
so the inherent like it was assumed that
we were on the same side of like
wild to ask people [ __ ] like that i
didn't get that from you i don't
remember but you don't remember the
conversation
i didn't say because it seems like
you're still friend i don't want to sit
there and say
she's an [ __ ] we're not friends okay
she's an [ __ ] but i think humanity
never won't be friendly okay i was
saying all i'm saying is that
i think that's insane and uh the nerve
of someone to come into your house that
you bought
the house that neil built as a friend
who wanted to say to his wife
the sushi's not free the wife who was
complaining about him working
he wanted to yell the sushi is not free
yeah no that's funny
i mean i think i was on your side i just
called you a little [ __ ]
joking away you know not this week
that was last week but okay
any other axes to grind
any other exes it's arnold's
arnold schwarzenegger's sword it is
affording it encounter an account
uh forging it um all right very good
thank you for listening and america
rest in power king
[Music]
you were great
[Music]
[Music]
um